notre invité politique ce matin c'est
claude malhuret bonjour dont je ne veux
connaître avec nous sénateur de l'allier
vous êtes président du groupe les
indépendants république et territoires
ici au sénat et on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représenté par creissels bertrand du
groupe la dépêche pour christelle
bonjour oriane dont jean-claude même
jour claude malhuret vous l'avez sans
doute entendu emmanuel macron s'est
exprimé hier à 20h heure française à la
tribune de l'assemblée générale de l'onu
assez ferme emmanuel macron hier il a
mis en garde il a mis les pays face à un
choix c'est le choix de la guerre ou de
la paix fut il a fustigé la russie elle
a alerté sur le risque d'une nouvelle
partition du monde qu'avez vous pensé de
ce discours je pense que c'était le bon
discours et le bon ton jeu on peut peut
être pour ou contre admet-elle macro on
a toujours des rapports un président de
la république d
des remarques à faire et tout mais là
franchement
c'était le discours qu'il fallait et je
dirais d'ailleurs que c'était attendu
parce que jusqu'à présent la france bien
entendu à aider l'ukraine l'aide est
fortement mais au niveau des paroles
c'était peut-être un petit peu plus un
petit peu plus ou moins résolu que les
discours de bail donne par exemple que
les discours de dd anglais donc qui
montre de fermeté oui je pense qu'il
fallait qu'il fallait que nous que tous
les deux que toute l'europe d'ailleurs
montre plus de fermeté en tout cas toute
l'europe de l'ouest qui est un petit peu
un petit peu en décalage par rapport à
l'europe de l'est mais c'était
absolument nécessaire et c'était le bon
ton et le et le bon suivi un vrai
changement de ton chez le président de
la république qui jusqu'à présent disait
il faut pas émettre les poutines là il
est beaucoup plus je pense que du marché
depuis le mais ce changement tant leur
marque depuis un mois depuis un mois
seul le ton a changé
emmanuel s'est aperçu que poutine
balader tout le monde
que
la position qui consistait à dire la
position de discussions de négociations
il a compris évidemment qu'avec poutine
en discutait pas qu'avec un colonel du
kgb on ne discutait pas qui se moquait
du monde surpris qu'il discutait qu'il
faisait semblant et encore il fait à
peine 100 blanc et
que désormais il n'y a pas le choix
d'autant plus que jusqu'à présent
l'ukraine bousquet ya un mois ou deux
l'ukraine pouvait paraître en position
délicate et tout aujourd'hui on est à un
tournant dans le discours qui consiste à
dire il faut parler avec poutine parce
que il faut pas trop
excité les ukrainiens s'étaient aussi ce
discours était était un bon discours est
aujourd'hui les ukrainiens montre que
qui est qui sont en train bien des
arguments du président la république
pour tenir un discours très nuancée
était une fois pas humilier boutique
parce qu'il faut déjà préparer la paix
oui aujourd'hui préparent plus la paix
je pense que
vous pouvez penser ça je pense que ce
qui moi ce que je reproche si j'ai un
projet faire c'était de le dire quand
les ukrainiens sont en train de se faire
envahir par papa par les russes
le sujet c'est pas de dire on va
préparer des discussions avec goûter à
ce que saab semble vouloir dire de toute
façon
ça va bien se passer pour les ukrainiens
donc voilà est-ce que est-ce qu'il
prépare si le poids pour la guerre vous
me demandez ce qui inclut la paix en
tous les cas
avec la guerre elle est là que poutine a
déclenché qu'on est en guerre qu'il est
en guerre contre l'ukraine et excusez
moi mais c'est ma position depuis le
début il est en guerre contre nous il
est un gain contre les démocraties les
indiens contre l'europe il est en guerre
on al impression d
indifférence à venir on conserve bien
sûr et je quitte ce qui est un petit peu
ennuyé c'est que nous européens pas les
américains ils ont compris ils pas les
anglais ils ont compris mais que nous
les européens on a l'air de se dire non
n'est pas vraiment en guerre alors que
la guerre est à nos portes alors que la
chine et l'urss la chine et la russie
pardon vous voyez quand je parle de
boutines évidemment je me suis
immédiatement et urss mais et kgb mais
eux ils savent très bien qu'ils sont en
guerre contre nous en guerre à long
terme en guerre de dictature contre les
démocraties en guerre économique en
guerre militaire en ukraine en guerre
cyber
un peu partout et par conséquent il est
temps de faire comprendre ici en france
mais dans tous les pays démocratiques et
aussi c'est ce qu'il a fait dans les
autres pays du monde que cette guerre
les menaces se dire d
alimentation en afrique oui en français
là bas il ya différentes personnes il ya
les idiots utiles
il ya ceux qui ne s'en occupe pas et qui
croit qu'on est loin qu'un et puis il ya
les collabos excusez moi du terme mais
il ya les collabos vous savez qu'ils
sont qui j'avais écouté le savez écouter
la conférence de presse de marine le pen
il ya quelques jours vous en avez parlé
mais c'est honteux et c'est pas la seule
l'extrême droite et l'extrême gauche ont
toujours été les caniches de poutine
aujourd'hui ils en sont les carpettes et
quand on dit il faut pas de sanction il
faut par mais les ukrainiens et terrasse
ça veut dire il faut laisser poutine
faire ce qu'il veut en ukraine et et
gagner en ukraine c'est un discours de
collabo et d'ailleurs c'est pas étonnant
de ce bleu plein part de ce parti qui
était quel tissu avec qui est issue
d'une bande de paix tennis au départ
c'est c'est dans son adn aujourd'hui oui
je dis c'est un discours de collabo je
suis pas le seul à le dire est ce que
vous ne craignez pas qu'une partie de
l'opinion publique avec l'augmentation
des prix de l'énergie n'écoute avec une
oreille attentive ses discours c'est
exactement ce que je pense de moi
c'était exactement ce que je crains et
c'est pour ça que je dis n'écoutez pas
ces discours les ukrainiens mais ça
suffit de dire n'écoutez pas ces disques
mais est ce que c'est vrai qu'est-ce que
j'ai d'autres lots d'autres armes que je
devais parler
les aides pour qu' elles sont là mais
elles vont elles vont être allégée
en tout cas je vous voyais bien
qu'aujourd'hui la france est le pays
d'europe c'est où les boucliers des les
boucliers sont les plus importants ou le
prix de l'électricité ammann n'a pas
doublé ou triplé comme en angleterre en
europe dans d'autres pays où l on a
prévu qu'elle augmente au maximum de 15%
c'est le le le le but du bogie et
tarifaires et par conséquent bien sûr
qu'il faut faire ça bien sûr il faut
faire ça mais vous êtes sénateur
[Musique]
il faut faire plus pour les
collectivités
toute la discussion du projet de loi de
finances va portement en ski de bosses
et des collectivités locales une bonne
partie la delà du projet de loi de
finances va porter là dessus et bien
entendu qu'il va falloir mettre à jour
notable que j'étais au congrès des
régions qui évalue à vichy je suis moi
fâché c'est nous
qui a lu il ya trois jours où évidemment
pas seulement les maires mais les
présidents de régions et présidents de
départements en poser ce problème donc
le symbole et le problème d'abord que
c'est une discussion qui va avoir lieu
au parlement l'assemblée au sénat et
deuxièmement pour moi le sujet c il va
falloir que tout le monde fasse des
efforts il va falloir que l'état fasse
un effort alors que les collectivités
locales aussi fait un effort il valoir
que comme vous le disait alors que les
particules bien sûr qu'on va avoir un
point qui va falloir baisser le
chauffage qui va peut-être qu'on va
payer plus cher mais il faut bien se
rendre compte quand je disais 1 à 100
que c'est pas une situation
tranquille que nous que l'ukraine est en
guerre mais que nous sommes aussi en
guerre que les dictatures que sont
notamment la chine mais on vous remet
attend aujourd'hui l'iran et cetera la
chine la russie les anges d'autre que
les dictatures ont décidé de remettre en
question l'ordre mondial actuel de
remettre en question les démocraties de
préconiser leurs modèles et de le faire
y compris par les armes donc voilà ce
qu'il faut c'est d'ailleurs les français
je crois le comprennent quand vous lisez
les sondages et son histoire inquiet de
2 pour leur pouvoir d'achat ils sont
inquiets de l'inflation ils sont 1 clé
du prix de l'énergie mais en même temps
une majorité et ça m'a d'ailleurs
agréablement surpris une majorité dans
le dernier sondage à la bhl qui a eu il
ya deux jours 67 % soutiennent les
sanctions ayant bien compris qu'il
fallait que les ukrainiens meurt et que
nous il va falloir qu'on se prive quand
même un petit peu pour pour les soutenir
et pour gagner cette guerre sur ce qui
se passe en europe il ya une poussée de
l'extrême droite historique en suède
en coalition avec la droite l'extrême
droite pourrait bien diriger l'italie à
partir de dimanche et à des législatives
est ce que pour vous c'est un mouvement
de fond est ce que vous êtes inquiet que
ça touche la france c'est un mouvement
de fond depuis
depuis 20 ans et c'est un moment qui a
déjà eu des conséquences extrêmement
qu'est ce que c'est c'est le mouvement
comment dire je disais tout à l'heure
c'est la guerre entre les dictatures et
les démocraties mais cette guerre elle a
un front intérieur dans les démocraties
c'est la lutte des populistes contre les
démocrates c'est l'extrême droite et les
cinq gauche qui sont aujourd'hui non pas
majorité m extrêmement représentés à
l'assemblée nationale mais ce mouvement
là il est là depuis longtemps il a donné
le break site avec l'aide de poutine il
a donné trump avec l'aide de poutine il
a donné un bol sonar où il a donné
sorbonne et cetera et puis de temps en
temps les avantages c'est que une fois
que les dix que les populistes sont au
pouvoir bon c'est vrai que ça marche pas
on s'aperçoit que que trump ça marche
pas on s'aperçoit global zone euro ça
marche pas on s'aperçoit vite que roban
ça marche ça marche pas et par
conséquent oui ce mouvement existe
depuis longtemps il va continuer je note
néanmoins
que sait pas c'est pas si simple que ça
ensuite ce n'est pas l'exemple de voir
ce sera à droite
et
et en france russie on est bien placé
pour le savoir et je note aussi que
meloni qui va sans doute gagner italie
lettonie l'extrême droite mais quel
navire est sûre sur la russie et qu'elle
a dit l'italie sera comme toute l'europe
elle appliquera les gens ne chantent
c'est donc c'est un peu plus compliqué
mais ce que vous me dites là évident
c'est ce qui se passe depuis c'est le
grand danger que nous avons les
démocraties sont confrontés aux
dictatures à l'extérieur et aux
populistes à l'intérieur la différence
dans les démocraties et les dictatures
c'est que en démocratie on peut parler
donc l'opposition est là et c'est sa
faiblesse je dirai évidemment c'est son
honneur c'est aussi sa faiblesse par
rapport aux dictatures le moi ce qui me
rend optimiste c'est que dans l'une dans
le passé on l'a vu on a vu souvent et
que les dictatures ont toujours un
avantage tactique au départ mais qu'en
général elles finissent par perdre les
conflits par paire les guerres mais par
perdre les affrontements avec les
démocraties
de l'arrêt fin de la rentrée
parlementaire ça va être la réforme des
retraites le président de la république
a reçu un certain nombre de députés la
semaine dernière il semble ressortir de
cette réunion qu'il a vraiment envie de
passer par le plfss pour réformer les
retraites le modem a déjà menacé de ne
pas voter ce texte s'il était imposé par
voie d'amendement
qu'est ce que le groupe des indépendants
sénart ferait alors
pour moi ce qui est important
c'est le fond du texte les retraites
c'est clair cette réforme nous sommes
pour nous sommes pour depuis le début ça
fait plusieurs années qu'elle a été
interrompu pour cause de pour cause de
covin mais nous sommes nous sommes pour
cette retraite nous arrivons à changer
ce qu'elle est oui oui mais je dirais
que
le discours très simple qui consiste à
dire il ya trois solutions puisque plus
on est d'accord avec le constat il ya un
déséquilibre seule équipe va s'amplifier
dès 2020 2023 2024
par conséquent il faut des trois
solutions l'augmentation des cotisations
par les temps qui courent c'est c'est
qu'on peut pas le rose et la baisse des
pensions retraites pour les mêmes
raisons évidemment personne ne veulent
pas des dons qu'il ne reste qu'une
solution et tout le monde le sait c'est
l'augmentation du temps de travail c'est
l'augmentation soit de l'âge soit de la
durée de cotisation à 30 là dessus sur
le fond bien de moi je ne vois pas qui
peut être content mais je vois qu'il ya
des gens qu'on ne voit pas quel accueil
ty nous on est pour alors maintenant le
buzz le problème sur le fond quand même
un certain nombre d'acteurs recrue ordre
on regrette l'abandon de la réforme
systémique
et même au sein de la majorité vous le
regrettez pas ça moi je suis je me suis
rendu compte au fur et à mesure bien sûr
que je bien sûr que je suis vraiment je
suis bien sûr que notamment il va
falloir parler de l'unification du
système de retraites mais bien entendu
mais enfin conclu mais c'est exclu en
tout cas pour l'heure parce que un jour
ou l'autre une là aussi une majorité de
français sont pour le fait que tout le
monde que les règles soient les mêmes
pour tout le monde et que les régimes
spéciaux
ça suffit voilà maintenant et en est
quand vous avez eu la polémique il ya
deux ou trois ans hurle sur le système
des retraites
quand vous voyez à nouveau les
polémiques alors que pourtant il me
semble que les solutions sont assez
pragmatique est assez simple ben vous
vous dites je vous comprenez que que le
gouvernement se disent on va peut-être
pas tout faire à la fois parce que sinon
[Musique]
on a bien compris vous étiez pour cette
réforme il fallait travailler plus
longtemps mais sur la méthode si ça
passe par un amendement dans le budget
de la sécurité sociale vous le vôtre est
est ce que ça peut être la bonne méthode
alors je on va voir ce qu'ils vont voir
ce qui se passe mais moi je suis pas je
ne lève pas les bras au ciel en étant
choqués nous sommes au sénat vous avez
sans doute remarqué que tous les ans au
sénat depuis trois ans la majorité
sénatoriale vote dans le plfss un
amendement disant il faut que que l'âge
de la retraite d'ici 2030 va être être
augmentée pour aisément jusqu'à 65 ans
donc ce que le gouvernement propose
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs il propose pas ça
ils bruce moins que ça il vaut aux hug
enfin il prouvera qu'on n'a pas la
proposition définitive vous savez trois
ans que le sénat la majorité sénatoriale
et nous votons dans le plfss
cette cet amendement est aujourd'hui je
ne vais pas me veux pas me mettre
[Musique]
je pense que républicains ont pas besoin
de mon message et ils l'ont veut event
ca et cc l'heure c'est leur sujet les
intérêts
que ça arrive que ça arrive a rapidement
qu'il ya peut-être eu que le temps de la
discussion je comprends ce que dit le
gouvernement ce projet question est-ce
qu'il faut plus de temps que vous
appelle pas plus mais sur le principe
d'un amendement du plfss il faut pas
même les gens qui montent sur leurs
grands chevaux pas rigoler on fait ça il
bat jeunes ce jeu pour tout vous dire je
sais pas si les sénateurs modem depuis
trois ans votent cette cette partie ou
ne votent pas c'est parti donc le sila
vote ce sera encore plus à un congrès
mais il est possible qu'ils
s'abstiennent ou qui ne pas donc je vais
pas là dessus depuis trois ans mais le
contexte a un peu changé là on est en
pleine crise énergétique les français
sont inquiets est-ce que c'était le bon
moment pour représenter cette réforme
une partie d'ailleurs des députés de la
majorité en doute ils ont demandé au
président la république de reporter à
2023 vous pensez que c'est elle c'est le
bon moment pour vous savez pour faire
passer ce texte là vous pensez qu'il ya
un bon moment pour allonger la durée de
cotisation ou allongée la
dernière fois qu'on a essayé ça passe a
pas été simple non ce genre de réforme
et c'est toujours une agent qui n'est
pas populaire c'est à chaque fois quand
le gouvernement fait quelque chose on
aimerait toujours mieux qu'il le fasse à
autrui facebook vous mais c'est comme ça
alors bien entendu on est au milieu de
multiples griller tout et il est cet
argument qui consiste à dire mais il
faut laisser le temps à diffuser à tous
moi je l'entends c'est peut-être comme
ça qu'il faut faire le gouvernement va
avoir à décider à prendre une décision
difficile est ce qu'il faut faire ça
tout de suite quitte à être accusé de
passer en force ou est-ce qu'il faut
dire oui quitte à ce que ce soit reporté
aux calendes grecques parce que c'est ce
qui s'est passé hier fois mais
voilà c'est un vrai sujet c'est une
vraie question moi j'ai pas d'avis
trancher là dessus à part l'intégration
gros dossiers qui arrivent au parlement
un projet de loi immigration qui a été
annoncé par le président de la
république pour le début de l'année
prochaine d'ici là gérald darmanin veut
organiser deux des balles on à
l'assemblée l'autre au sénat est ce que
vous vous y est favorable est ce que
vous y participeraient alors
oui bien sûr je suis favorable et on
peut en tant que parlementaire quatre
favorables moi ce que je remarque c'est
que ce n'est pas le seul débat c'est à
dire que depuis qu'elle isabelle borne a
été nommé premier ministre
elle a annoncé est l'annoncé de
multiples débats et elle a expliqué l'a
dit dans son discours
introductif quand elle est
quand elle quand elle a été nommée elle
l'a dit à l'assemblée elle a dit au
sénat qu'elle allait multiplier les
concertations et elle l'a fait puisque
nous avons dans quelques jours le débat
sur l'énergie un débat arctique 50-1
c'était un débat général qu'on parle à
l'assemblée et au sénat nous avons
quinze jours plus tard un débat sur
l'ukraine à l'assemblée et au sénat et
nous avons ce débat sur l'immigration
qui est annoncée donc bien entendu qu'on
peut que se réjouir qu il y ait des
débats en amont de la présentation d'un
projet de loi sur la proposition de
magna la con oui de répartir les
étrangers sur le territoire national et
notamment dans les zones rurales qui
sont en voie de désertification
vous pensez c'est une bonne proposition
que tes potes dans ce débat il va y
avoir des tas de bois moi je sais tu as
et une ce comment dire c'est une
proposition qui arrive comme ça sur la
table sans qu'on ait vraiment réussi je
voudrais faire peut-être une ou deux
remarques la première c'est que moi
j'habite dans une ville moyenne j'ai été
pendant longtemps le maire d'une ville
moyenne de vichy
il faut pas penser que tout que tous les
immigrés sont aujourd'hui en région
parisienne en région lyonnaise ou en
région marseillaise ils sont aujourd'hui
déjà sur tout le territoire il y à vichy
et moulins à montluçon partout dans les
villes moyennes et même dans le
oui enfin bon départements l'allier est
un département rural alors il ya des
villes moyennes et puis il ya des
heureux la ruralité à proprement parler
mais mais mais voilà il ya aujourd'hui
il faut pas penser qu'il ya des immigrés
quelques parts égales dans métro c'est
une bonne idée de repeupler ces hommes
et de ces femmes moi je dirais d'abord
je sais pas que cette proposition il
faut la creuse et parce que je vois pas
comment on met en france on dire les
gens vont y veulent on est on est pas en
n'est pas en russie on n'est pas en
chine les gens s'ils veulent s'installer
vous ciblez les installer en général et
qu'ils sont pas contents ils vont
revenir ailleurs donc c'est quelque
chose c'est d'une proposition comme qui
me paraît brut de décoffrage
et en tout cas qu'il faut vraiment qu'il
faut préciser parce que comme ça
présenté comme ça
elle a dit c'est un mépris pour les
locaux c'est une négation de l'identité
de nos communes et elle en a profité sur
ce pour lancer sa campagne sénatoriale
en disant en appelant les élus locaux à
voter pour elle parce que je cite jamais
les sénateurs elle ne laisserait faire
ça qu'est ce que vous en pensez oui je
je pense que le débat là dessus
comment dire je suis pas sûr que je sois
là
la meilleure façon de placer le débat il
n'en reste pas moins qu'aujourd'hui ça
veut dire que ça fait le jeu du
rassemblement national non je veux dire
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde sait qu'il
y a des ghettos tout le monde sait qu'il
ya des zones de non-droit tout le monde
sait qu'il ya des concentrations dans un
certain nombre de départements et
notamment dans les métropoles et qu' il
va bien falloir d'une façon ou d'une
autre
arrêtez c'est comment dire à arrêter la
façon dont ça se danse à augmentent sans
arrêt que la première la première façon
de faire c'est évidemment de maîtriser
l'immigration de contrôler les arrivées
de réussir à faire en sorte que les
expulsions puisse se faire tout ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui mais ce qui
me paraît la première urgence après on
verra il est vrai que pour casser nature
comme moi d'un département rural c'est
une proposition qui est un peu brut de
décoffrage surprenante et donc j'attends
de voir qu'est ce que ça veut dire dans
les précisions dans l'eure et loir qui
pratique cette politique edouard
philippe tenait ces jeux les journées
parlementaires de son parti horizon à
fontainebleau ce week-end vous en étiez
on a du mal à comprendre le rôle qu'il
entend occuper dans les prochains mois
est ce qu'on fait nous expliquer je
crois qu'il l'a expliqué en deux mots
lorsqu'il a créé horizons
il a dit libre et loyale
et par conséquent loyal ça veut dire
qu'il fait partie de la majorité qui est
d'ailleurs ils le montrent bien il l'a
montré au congrès de la renaissance ce
week-end y compris d'ailleurs sur le
thème de la réforme des retraites il a
il a interdit spécifiquement lassus
notamment donc loyal à la majorité est
libre parce que nous avons une
sensibilité politique qui est grosso
modo celle du centre-droit avec un
certain nombre de propositions
existent extrêmement discret quand même
c'est pour ne pas gêner manuellement non
c'est parce que je pense c'est parce que
sa stratégie est une stratégie
de long terme c'est une stratégie
horizon on veut bien dire cela ça veut
dire on regarde de loin on
2027 on regarde de loin c'est à dire je
parle de la
des propositions et des du sujet de la
france dans les années qui vient qui
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs je suis très
surpris qui aujourd'hui ne regarde pas
2025 j'étais très très surpris parce que
le lendemain de l'élection d' emmanuel
macron je n'ai plus les politiques et
les journalistes
ne parlait que de 2000 je pensais que ça
viendrait dans deux trois ans après les
européennes mais c'est venu tout de
suite donc roi pas reprocher à la
personne de parler de 2011 c'est parce
que tout le monde parle de 2027 c'est la
première fois et fédérer également qu on
est dans cette situation au président
une dernière question sur les
accusations de harcèlement et de
violence qui vise certains députés de la
nuque aujourd'hui
jean luc mélenchon a réagi pardon par
des tweets aux accusations visant adrien
catena et isabelle bande a eu des mots
assez durs en disant qu'il banalise et
les violences conjugales est ce que vous
partagez ce point de vue
je vous savez je suis pas surprise sur
sept qui veut faire l'ange fait la bête
et on s'aperçoit bien depuis d'ailleurs
l'élection depuis ce qui se passe à
l'assemblée nationale le foutoir
permanent la conflictuelle isation de
tous les maux de mélenchon lui même ce
parti est un parti est un parti extrême
c'est un parti violent c'est un parti
qui prêchent la violence qui prêchent la
révolution violente qui prêchent le
conflit permanent etc il est composé de
gens qui sont des extrêmes et en général
quand les gens sont des extraits mais
pas quand ces gens sont des extrêmes
politiques en général eh ben c'est pas
par hasard qu'on retrouve et qu'on va et
qu'on va en retrouver de bulles en plus
chaque jour il y avait encore un
aujourd'hui je me rappelle plus en eau
chaque jour amène cela rien à jouer non
je ne parle pas de bananes d'ananas il y
en a un nouveau et par conséquent moi je
suis voilà bien entendu que elisabeth on
a raison bien entendu que la réaction de
mélenchon et je suis pas le seul de tout
le monde tout le monde dans son propre
parti tout le monde l'a dénoncée dans la
dénonçait une réaction une réaction d'un
sexisme incroyable qui d'ailleurs
correspond
ligne politique à la une politique
depuis que mélenchon est elle aussi
l'organisation communiste
internationaliste le début c'est
l'organisation c'était il ya des années
et des années l'organisation la plus
sexiste la plus virile hills pour parler
comme sandrine rousseau qui existent ça
continue aujourd'hui on défend non pas
la victime et celui qui lui a mis une
gifle en disant qu'il a eu raison de
jean claude malhuret parce que le temps
file mais pardon je reviens dans l'air
puisque vladimir poutine s'est exprimé
dit que l'occident est en train essaye
de détruire la russie c'est ce qu'il dit
et ils annoncent une mobilisation
partielle en russie est ce que c'est un
tournant annoncé une mobilisation
partielle est ce que ces actes et qu'il
est en guerre alors que jusqu'à
maintenant il parlait seulement
d'opérations spéciales à son peuple oui
ça veut dire qu'il est ça veut dire
simplement qu'il est aux abois
l'occident veut descendre dans la rue si
pour le moment c'est la russie qui veut
détruire l'ukraine dans le le le
discours de poutine est un discours
comme tout colonel du kgb depuis des
années des années qui est le mensonge
systématique quand il dit quelque chose
vous pouvez certain que c'est le
contraire qui est vrai deuxièmement plus
ils menacent plus ça montre qu'il est
aux abois on sait mayila menacé pour la
première fois de la bombe atomique quand
il a commencé à être mal an du tri est
prête à utiliser tous les moyens sauf
que vous avez et de ce point de vue là
c'est important tient la réunion de
samarcande avec la chine et l'inde
montrent que de toute évidence inutile
ce sa menace est une menace ben il
n'utilisera pas la bombe atomique parce
que la chine et l'inde lui en dit
maintenant ça suffit parce que le
kazakhstan lui a dit je quitte le stcc
dire l'organisation de shanghai je
quitterai le kazakhstan qui est vraiment
qui a été secouru enfin dans le
dictateur a été secouru par poutine il
ya un an seulement
poutine est aux abois sur le plan
militaire il est aux abois sur le vent
et plus il est aux abois plus ils
menacent fortement il est en train de
mettre en place et référendum bidon
organisé en trois jours en plus dans une
région en guerre c'est effarant donc
tout ce que dit poutine est faux et
deuxièmement plus poutine menace plus
cela montre qu'il est aux abois donc
c'est pas là c'est pas le moment de
lâcher les ukrainiens ou non ils sont en
train de gagner et au boot inn est en
train comme je le disais d'ailleurs au
sénat trois jours après l'invasion qu'il
perdrait et que son régime serait mais
ce serait seraient détruits par cette
guerre donc on y est on y est presque et
poutine évidemment plus c est plus que
l'on zappé lui crie fort mais plus écrit
fort plus ça montre qu'il est faible
merci merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
[Musique]